dieses jahr feiert voice of germany sein
zehnjähriges jubiläum allerdings nicht
mit rapper sido und erließ merten für
die jubiläumsstaffel stehen bisher nur
mark foster und rea garvey fest jetzt
kam raus dass yvonne catterfeld und auch
samu haber zur show zurückkehren werden
und jetzt verraten wir dir exklusiv bei
place to be wer außerdem in der jury
2020 dabei es ist silbermond sängerin
stefanie kloß
sie war bereits 2016 für zwei jahre in
der jury und kommt jetzt zurück wir sind
gespannt auf ihr comeback auf eine
erfolgreiche sängerin aber noch nicht in
dem alter um in einer jury zu sitzen ist
blue ali carter mit gerade einmal acht
jahren tritt sie in die fußstapfen ihrer
eltern beyoncé und jay sie und gewinnt
ihren ersten bj mit dem preis werden
afro amerikanische künstler und menschen
aus minderheits gruppen geehrt wurde für
den song browns king girl ausgezeichnet
ein titel auf beyoncés neuem album
[Musik]